alright folks here we are once again my
last episode of tales from the comment
section so Thor Ragnarok got a lot of
love from you guys and I appreciate that
oh he's nervous branching out trying new
things but I just thought this will be
fun so I'm glad you guys thought it was
fun too and this brings us to the next
episode as before all these comments
you're about to hear are actual comments
from the comments section of the movie
at hand here to read the comments is
douchey me are you ready
great just a forewarning there are some
slight spoilers in here not game
breaking spoilers for the movie but
still lights boards most of it general
knowledge at this point but a figure you
should be warned so let's get on to the
comment section
judges League mostly all DC feels like
it's directed by a thirteen-year-old the
flash may be comic relief but that sweet
way that we're designed it's like a kid
said let's make a suit that is a fusion
between Iron Men and the Red Power
Ranger well is shoulder pads I'm gonna
assume you mean suit not sweets the
material from his suit is heat-resistant
that comes from the space shuttle that's
explained in the movie but the armored
aspect of it is because when he's going
that fast bugs and flies and things he
hits are like pellets and bb's hitting
him so he needs to be armored up really
doesn't explain where flash got the
materials to make this suit in which
case maybe flash stole the materials to
make the suit or stole the suit in which
case flash is a bit of a hypocritical
thief here oh so that's interesting why
the four ttle combat does WB cut out the
movies why of course Justice League is
going to need more than two hours to be
able to tell the story right
this is them just trying to optimize the
money the movie could make per
auditorium per day if you have a movie
that has a runtime of about three hours
which was about the initial cut of
Justice League then you could only show
that movie about three times per
auditorium showing the movie per day but
if the movie is less than two hours you
can get about four or five so I imagine
they were like eh hopefully that
translates to more money didn't help but
that was the thought process you
Marvel Thor Ragnarok was the worst movie
I feel like you're commenting on the
wrong video I feel like you want to be
commenting on my Thor Ragnarok reviews
the only way your comment would make
sense that's me giving you the benefit
of the doubt because there's no way you
would want to perpetuate some hate in
the comment section now not you douche
I forgot I had YouTube set to have speed
and wondered if Jeremy had a stroke it's
actually kind of funny I wonder what
that would sound like fun discussions
bring on the fan discussions talking
about Justice League DC Comics Marvel
comic 1 I want some new a guy who talked
like that
so that's funny too that really brings
out the flaws in my speech pattern so I
got to work on that red notice however
since comic book movies have really
kicked into gear the overall ratings
from everyone have gotten lower though I
do agree with the sentiment of human
beings when something's new they tend to
hold it in higher regard than when you
know 10 years later as of now they've
seen it before but if you're looking at
the tomato meter and Rotten Tomatoes
spider-man homecoming Wonder Woman Thor
Ragnarok but I'll contradict your
assessment if you're talking about me
and my channel and my ratings spider-man
homecoming and Logan those both came out
this year so it's just with all the data
it people like what they like just stop
turning around the controversy and call
it a bad film with some good moments
controversy really I think you
misunderstand the word controversy have
you not seen controversy in the past
month on Twitter that's controversy
what's controversial about this movie
what's controversial about Justice
League at all please tell me yeah
exactly there's no controversy there
what do they bring Kevin Spacey back to
be Lex Luthor that would be a
controversy now there's nothing like
that here unless you're talking about
the CGI moustache in which case it's
still not a controversy no that's weird
I learned from BBS in Suicide Squad to
not waste my money on the cutout version
of a movie I will wait for the extended
edition on blu-ray not sure why they
want to give us an unfinished product no
friggin thanks I understand what you're
saying and before I kind of explained
why they wanted to make it under two
hours and I totally want to see the Zack
Snyder cut I would love to see the two
movie arc that Zack Snyder initially
planned we're not going to get that so
an extended 1 episode arc that would be
cool too judging by the box office I
don't think we're gonna get that I'm not
gonna hold my breath on it so you
probably shouldn't either so if you're
gonna say you should probably just see
the version you're gonna get because
this is probably the version you're
going to get why the have I been
getting ads in Spanish when I view your
channel Jeremy Jones oh I don't know
because I don't have any control over
what ads play on my
Tube channel however as I understand it
the ads that you see are based on your
search algorithm so as a me this rosetta
stone or spanish-born
what you're looking at what is it don't
make it weird just be honest it's okay
so this is the comment section of the
spoiler free reviews I'm not going to
talk about that my spoiler free review
because I would consider that a spoiler
even though they addressed the fact that
henry cavill was coming back for the
movie they didn't show anything about
him so didn't want to talk about it
wanna spoil it for the people so you
gotta wait till my spoiler talk that
comes after the movie before you
actually meltdown on the fact I didn't
talk about Superman if I didn't in the
spoiler talk that would have been weird
wait relax again with everything I just
said to the previous comment just apply
that here there it is the MCU films are
bad because they have poorly developed
villains I didn't say that but that's
when a poorly developed a villain
appears in a DC you film that's the
point
Steppenwolf can take a backseat if they
heroes get the French again with the
misquoting of me I have to assume you're
quoting me because I actually did say
this portion of it I did say Steppenwolf
can take a backseat if the heroes take
the front seat but I never said MCU
movies are bad because they have
underdeveloped villains I have addressed
the fact that MCU movies have had
underdeveloped villains but I did not
say MCU movies are bad and I have not
said they're bad because they have
underdeveloped villains so I where's
that coming from
not all reviewers are alike you can't
take something someone said over there
and apply it to what I say here Chris
Nolan changed the game for comic-book
movies so it's impossible not to compare
these movies to the Dark Knight trilogy
and they just fall short well you are
right you can think to yourself that the
Joker when you said you changed things
forever there's no going back could be
talking to Christopher Nolan himself but
it's important to not compare Justice
League to Christopher Nolan's Batman you
can't do that you shouldn't do that you
also shouldn't compare the Tim Burton
Batman's to Christopher Nolan's Batman
Christopher Nolan made a world it's very
unique to Christopher Nolan's world very
grounded in reality for the most part so
when they make a Justice League movie
you shouldn't compare it granted I have
done
that where it's like a joker was in the
forefront here he's a villain who stands
out but they didn't do it here so you
can compare certain elements but try not
to do it for the overall thing because
it's just it is gonna fall flat you're
right you're setting it up for failure
haven't watched a single superhero since
Suicide Squad and never will no comic
book movies at all you watched none of
them you Logan was coming out you were
like I'm not gonna watch Logan because
Suicide Squad that has nothing to do
with each other that defies logic and
reason on every level and you've only
missed out because of it so that's
strange
when they go into the alien ship thing
it's night and when Superman is brought
back to life and they fight it's
magically day I didn't know Superman had
those powers wow that totally did happen
my memory is a little fuzzy on it but I
do think you are right I thought it was
nighttime and they brought Superman back
to life and then it was daytime and they
all threw down and fought that's wow
good eye good catch that's what happens
when you have reshoots re-edits read
structure and two different directors
it's it's casual too it's collateral
damage is what it is that's what I'm
trying to say there but yeah that that
happens in Michael Bay movies do where
it's like it's daytime one car ride one
square mile now it's nighttime I don't
know why at first it's like your brain
doesn't pick it up and then you watch it
again you're like no I totally pick that
up so it can only last for so long you
can only trick people for about one
viewing especially in the social media
world you're not getting away with it
for too long so job and that's it folks
I SEPA sewed to of tales from the
comments section if I picked your
comment and douchy me read it in the
joushi way and you didn't mean it in a
douchey way please don't take offence
it's all in good fun and since this is a
bit of a new segment on my channel a bit
outside the box if you want to share
this around to your friends I'd really
appreciate that we need to have get it
around on social media that helps and
props to you guys a few comments aside a
lot of people were talking about how it
was going to be a venom war more than
there was actually a venom fanboy war in
the comment section so props to you yeah
I just don't see why we can't all get
along and enjoy both friends just
sucks to seize the best fight be her
[Applause]
[Music]
you